[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
this is the ramsey show we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
has meaning we help them to create and
have actual real relationships george
campbell ramsey personality and host of
the
better or the fine print podcast and the
entree leadership podcast is my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
your life and your money it's a free
call at triple eight eight two five five
two two five that's triple a eight two
five five two two five shannon starts
off this hour in carlsbad new mexico hi
shannon how are you good how are you
dave better than i deserve what's up
good
so i'm calling because i have a 2019
suburban that literally broke down on
the side of the road in the middle of
nowhere about two months ago
i finally found out that it needs a new
engine it's under warranty
and basically we are getting nowhere
with gm and finding out
an answer on when we will get a new
engine
i have a friend that owns a body shop
where we live
and i kind of said hey can you give us
some advice when do you think we would
possibly get a new engine because we're
getting nowhere with gm
he says let me make a few phone calls
and get back to you and basically said
i would start shopping for new vehicles
so here we are unplanned
trying to figure out should we wait
you know possibly the three four however
many months
to get my vehicle back since it is under
warranty it's completely paid for uh
you know we have the cash to pay for the
difference for a new vehicle but it's
just not the ideal time we weren't
planning on getting a new vehicle at all
now a crummy time to buy a car right now
it's terrible yeah
i'm sorry what a mess
so when you talk to the general motors
folks what are they telling you
so there
they it's basically a back and forth of
you know my husband's at this point
trying to see where we are in line
you know we could be 30 in line we could
be 900 in line and so they told us last
week you know we'll get back to you we
still haven't heard back um
it's basically going nowhere
well it's going somewhere based on the
size of the foot you put on their butt
true that's true they said they would
try to escalate it but not who knows if
they actually will it might actually
escalate for them
so you know i call the general manager
of the dealership and explain to them
you're getting ready to hire an attorney
okay because they're not they're not
honoring their warranty and you being
without a car is not okay and you know
let's jack them up
because this i'm guessing this is a
supply chain problem because it's not
general motors dna to be this uh
uncooperative usually they're very good
about stuff
yes and they basically are blaming
everything on covet and
supply chain they can't get an engine
out of the dead gum factory
well i'm gonna be calling them every day
for updates to you're the squeaky wheel
who gets the grease and on top of that
i'm going to go to the dealership and
say you're going to let me use a car
until this is fixed and you're going to
do it for free oh there's a good idea
yeah we've tried we've tried doing that
we've tried getting a loan they don't
have any cars again
yeah they said they don't have any
loaners because of covid and the the
hard part about it is too is that we
live in the middle of nowhere and our
car is in el paso texas two hours away
so it's not a thing you know where we
can go in there every day we have been
on the phone with um
you know the person in the
shop every day but basically that's
where they escalated it to gm
corporate and my husband's been in
communication with them yeah i think i'm
gonna be in touch with a regional
corporate guy and so you guys need to
get me a loan or i'm with george on that
that's a brilliant idea uh and guys we
understand that you got supply chain
problems but you need to understand i
also don't have a car
yes and so that's a bigger deal for me
than your supply chain problems
so get me a car exactly give me a car
yeah i'll be real understanding if you
get me a car bring me a car
okay
like bring me a car now yeah
okay yeah that's that's what we've been
trying to do and then yeah i know but i
i think you're being what we're saying
is we think you're being too nice
yeah
i channel your inner dave ramsey when
you show up
i know well and that's why we're going
back and forth and you know we've been
saying you know should we just go get a
different car because this is the second
major issue that we've had with this car
if you want to sell it that's fine sell
it after it's fixed but in the meantime
they should provide you a car if you if
you if you jack everybody up you still
don't get a car and you still don't get
an engine and you've got the money i
guess you're gonna have to go buy a car
aren't you
i know and then sell that one when it
gets fixed right
yes and that's what i that's another
thing because they're lowballing us
because we've tried to say hey what
would you give us for this and they're
lowballing us and
we do have the money to go we are in a
very blessed situation where just go buy
a car and get that car fixed and get it
sold
if you can't get a loaner
and i really am going to be talking to
the regional guys i've actually had two
people work for me over there that used
to be general motors regional
uh service reps and so they had regional
guys and i don't know if they still do
or not but that was a few years back but
uh and honestly they are trained
like no other to make customers happy
now i understand they can't make cars or
engines appear out of thin air but uh
but they can uh if you make it a big
enough deal and go listen i really don't
want to go legal on you guys but i'm
getting ready to hire an attorney
and we're gonna make you guys wish you
would loan me a car
yeah i agree because i'm at the point
where i'm i'm almost don't even want to
buy another gm vehicle ever yeah well i
mean you can tell them that too i mean
that that's understandable and and the
sad thing is they make great cars i've
owned them all my life but um
yeah
you know
it it it is what it is but here's the
thing
companies out there listening
you have legitimate supply chain issues
but your customer has legitimate
problems and your job as the company
solve the customer problem they don't
really care about your problem
they don't really care
yeah and a big part of this is to
realize you have options it's when you
realize well we gotta go get a new car
because i'm gonna be beating down their
door until we have a solution here and
the worst worst case is we get a
temporary car we resell it and hopefully
we don't lose any money drive the car or
buy the car you want to replace it with
and direct and then sell the
uh suburban when you get it fixed that's
fine that's the financing too you got
the money to do that it's just
inconvenient
and you shouldn't have to
you shouldn't have to they should they
should take care of you so and i got a
feeling if you lean in hard enough and
often enough that probably you're gonna
get that result
that was a good fix george that's a good
thing i always start with kindness and
then i get a little more firm when
things aren't going the way they should
and uh it's a hard thing to do with
customer service a lot of people have a
hard time
you know being the being bad cop yeah
well i don't yeah i don't want to just
start in chewing somebody out yeah but
we do need to you know click up click up
click up the heat as we go along and um
i mean you know if the food's not coming
from the kitchen it's like
hello
been an hour we need some food
you know and
we've talked about this a couple times
now do i need to talk to manager how can
i help you yeah then you need me to go
back there and help you cook i mean
what's the deal honey i would love to
see you back here in the kitchen food
needs to come out of the kitchen baby
you can grill
this happened the other day i'm just
saying this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we've taught cods and grandma's ways of
handling money for 30 years here at
ramsey and now my good friend and expert
dr john deloney is paving the way for
how we talk about relationships and
mental health his brand new book own
your past change your future has been on
sale now for eight days it's available
for purchase and it's a book everyone
needs to read it has personally changed
the language i use with others it's
changed me it changed george who knew
there we go this book is not just for
people who are healing from some
terrible traumatic experience the
practical steps packed in here apply to
everyone in every walk of life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old who's out of
college and looking to make friends the
mom and dad who want to connect with
their grown kids better or their young
kids better people coming out of abusive
relationships everyone every one of you
listening right now has a story
john took his two phds his 20 years of
counseling experience and packed it into
an easy to understand book pick up your
copy of own your past change your future
today for only 20 bucks at
ramseysolutions.com
don't miss this lori is in chicago hi
laurie welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
i am going to court tomorrow for a
credit card debt
um a
the credit card original company sold it
to a debt
buyer
and now the lawyer is suing me
and i tried settling two times
and they really wouldn't go down very
much it's the original debt is 8 500
and they went down as far as 59.85
i was just wondering if you had any
ideas of what i could do as far as
facing
a lawyer tomorrow or if i should still
try to call this company that's not
working with me they wanted me to make
payments and i know you're not for that
yeah i wouldn't do that it doesn't work
out well for you
um the lump sum settlement is the only
way to go have you got the money to
settle tomorrow
no not no i don't have that much i tried
settling um i can give them 2300. how
much do you think i got
2 300. okay what was the original debt
uh
85.50 that was the original debt
not what they say you owe
i'm not sure how how that exactly works
how much did you borrow how much was
owed when you quit paying it
well it went through another collection
agency it was sold again so no no that's
not what i'm asking i'm asking when you
quit paying the credit card
how much was owed
um
sorry years ago
um
nine i believe it was nine thousand
seven hundred and sixty six dollars no i
was making perfect no it wouldn't have
gone down
well i made i was making payments to
original cred uh
okay all right
well they probably as you've heard on
the show probably paid a nickel on the
dollar for it
right so they probably got five six
hundred bucks in this dad
um can you get any more together than
2500
well i have some save for my
my
taxes on my house
i mean
i'm very limited
maybe three 000 okay all right
or maybe if you use a little bit of that
tax money if you get rid of this it's
worth it okay if you go to 3 500 or 4
000 and you get rid of an eight or ten
thousand dollar debt it's going to be
worth it so here's what's going to
happen all right when you go into court
on a debt this size
you it's um very similar
this is not high drama
with matlock or some big high-powered
whatever you think of attorney on some
television show okay
this is more like going to traffic court
when you got a ticket that time
you ever done that
not that but i've done something else
okay you're going to a court when it was
like a big yawn
and it was all like a conveyor belt and
it was automatic and nobody cared and
there was no drama and there was no
shaming and there was nothing legal it
was just boom clip clip clip you're out
of there
that's what this is going to be
i
heard you once say
to um try to find the lawyer ahead of
time yes and make a deal then in the
hall yeah
otherwise walk up in front of the judge
and tell the judge you've tried to make
a deal
and you know that this is a debt buyer
and you know that they paid a nickel on
the dollar for it approximately because
that's under industry standard and i'm
standing here offering this guy three
thousand dollars and we can't get him to
take it your honor
and he's gonna shame the attorney then
because you're gonna be the only human
that showed up on this whole thing this
guy's got 200 cases all of them are on
automatic smackdown and no humans show
up except old laurie and there she
stands
so you're going to be like the
entertainment for the morning right
do they care about any of my
three no
nothing they don't care about your story
they don't think they don't care if
you're pitiful they don't care yeah
best thing it's just money okay it's
just very awkward very agnostic
there's no spirit to it there's no
morals to it it's just i want some money
and if you give me some money oh and i
don't like the money and then the you
tell the judge and here's the money and
the judge goes oh come on
it's gonna sound like that it's gonna be
like judge judy or something in here
right
okay you don't think that the lawyer
will or i mean the judge will say that
make payments he might
he might he might slap you with a
garnishment i don't know it's possible
but you don't have a lot of options here
your only option is settle it if you
can't settle it ask the judge to settle
it otherwise he's going he's going to
make you do something because he's going
to do that anyway
if you don't show up they're going to
get a judgment and they're going to
begin to garnish you
yeah i'll show up okay but i'm just
saying if you don't show you
automatically lose but by the way you're
in the wrong so you're automatically
going to lose anyway
i know the only question is can you just
you know by by being a human and being
there do you influence the process and
get a settlement
but you got really no defense you owe
the debt you didn't pay it there's no
defense
how old is this dad
um
it was from um well these guys purchased
it in 2020. when did you know okay
the last time i paid so it's a few years
old
18 2018. okay and what was it originally
what kind of credit card
uh the name of the credit card was
capital one okay all right
yeah they'll sue you on ten thousand
bucks they usually won't screw with it
on under five because it's not worth
their legal hassle
but the debt buyers sometimes will screw
with it if they buy it under five
and so
yeah this is a pretty substantial
account most debt is under five thousand
dollars per card
but good old capital one what's in your
wallet lawsuits
apparently man i haven't i haven't heard
a lot of situations where people are
going to court over the credit card debt
it doesn't happen very often
it's usually they just deal with the
debt settlement companies and they try
to negotiate that buyer will usually
settle and again folks they're buying
these things a nickel on the dollar
um
and you know we did this oh yeah
christmas before last week we paid off a
bunch of days yeah we bought 10 million
dollars worth of debt
from um from
a lot of it was medical debt
and uh we bought 10 million dollars for
a quarter on our for two and a half
percent paid 250 000 for it and we call
we had all of our uh eight our employees
get we gave them eight each there was
like um what uh there was like ten
thousand accounts roughly and uh they
each called and told people for
christmas that their debt was forgiven
so we bought 10 million dollars worth
and forgave it
and it was our christmas
it's what we did for christmas yeah we
had our favorite gift and it was a blast
but we bought that for 250 000 is 10
million a little north of 10 million
dollars so that's that's 25 cents on i
mean that's two and a half cents on the
dollar yeah we bought the whole book
there's the proof i mean now that was
old medical debt which is that by the
way it's usually cheaper to buy yeah
than on credit cards there was some car
loans in there too i remember calling
someone and saying we paid off yeah we
got a few credit cards in there i think
we got i think we probably got i don't
know a couple of hundred credit cards in
there but most of it was medical but so
you you can buy debt for a nickel on the
dollar and then go try to collect it um
anything they make over that is profit
yeah we didn't collect it we just sent
them all letters and a lot of them
thought we were scamming them oh yeah no
one believed me when i called they said
what i didn't ask you to do that's so
fun we got some great videos there were
some inspiring ones too a lot of people
just broke down and cried yeah it was
sweet but some people were just angry
with me yeah why are you calling me i'm
busy okay sorry sir have a good day just
calling to tell you you don't owe the
debt anymore what i didn't ask you to do
that are you ready
to do that who are you what are you the
grinch it's christmas oh my gosh too
funny it's a blast so yeah that's the
truth and so you can you can buy debt
like that and if you want to write big
checks anyway and so
that's kind of proof that what we're
saying is true that you can buy it for
nickelodeon which is why they want to
get nickel and the dollar on it and this
is uh good old citibank at your service
just think of that next time you see one
of those stupid buck commercials of
theirs this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net and get one thousand to
twenty five hundred dollars off of your
tuition again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on the debt free stage courtney is with
us hi courtney how are you i'm doing
great dave how are you i am better than
i deserve it oh i'd love to hear that
where do you live i live in houston
texas good fun welcome to nashville yes
all right how much debt have you paid
off i paid off a hundred and thirteen
thousand eight hundred and seventy four
dollars i love it and how long did that
take it took me thirty months good and
your range of income during that between
seventy four thousand to ninety thousand
cool what do you do for a living i am a
director of marketing i work in real
estate
good good and uh what kind of debt was
your hundred and fourteen thousand so
most of it about ninety four thousand of
it was from student loan debt and the
rest was for my car loan okay cool yeah
what'd you get your degree in i got my
degree in health science and biology it
was totally different from what my
career is that's okay yeah now you're
making money life's good yes and you
paid it off that's the other thing
that's good so good for you so how long
you been out of school i've been out of
school oh my god i graduated in 2012 so
it's been a really long time
eight eight nine years yeah all right
but but two and a half years ago
bing bing what happened okay so i've
been getting these mails from my you
know from fed loans saying you owe money
you owe money and i was talking to my
friend and she was like courtney just
look at it as a debt you'll pay for the
rest of your life
that's so pro that's so hopeful what
good friends
and i was like yeah i want better than
that so i came across your youtube
channel and i've been hooked ever since
i purchased the total money makeover i
listened to podcast i mean i was hooked
on you um and i got debt free because of
unison thank you for that well thank you
way to go you did the work yeah you're
impressive that's yeah we're about the
same age i graduate graduated the same
year with a lot less debt than you but
was that a slog to get through it was it
was a slog i had to really use that dead
snowball method to really take it piece
by piece because looking at it full-on i
was terrified i was like i'll never get
it done but doing it smaller by smaller
it helped me really accomplish that goal
yeah when you look at that debt and
you're like i don't even make that much
how am i ever going to make these
payments and you started doing the debt
snowball was there a moment where you
were like oh this is working i see the
progress yeah i think my third or fourth
loan i paid off i was like okay i can do
this chucking along and i had my mini
victories for those ones that i did pay
off so it made it much better getting to
the final destination that's fun what
was those mini victories did you
celebrate in some way i did celebrate i
might have bought a pair of shoes or
something small sorry dave you know i
wasn't on rice and beans the whole time
but i just had to you know give myself a
little treat show self-moments yeah yeah
so i got to do that for myself well
you're very reasonable yeah i might
celebrate but it wouldn't be shoes not
shoes but that's you know ken coleman he
would buy you yeah definitely would
definitely for sure oh that's awesome
congratulations thank you thank you who
was your biggest cheerleader my biggest
was um my parents were really good my
family
my boyfriend terence he was great helped
me out a lot all the way so yeah and you
clearly had some detractors there does
your friend now go wait you did it it
didn't take your whole life yeah another
like well courtney can you tell me more
about this debt snowball method who is
this dave ramsey person so i'm just
putting them all drinking the kool-aid
of dave ramsey so you just put debt free
in the search bar on youtube and there
we were there you were yeah there you
were that's how i found you yeah oh my
god so i mean literally even like my
passwords on my computer was like debt
free 2021 i really wrote a vision and
made it plain and i stick to that
habakkuk 3-3 i love it yeah well done
yeah write the vision and make it plain
okay that's good hey when you do that
something something snaps when you write
it down and you put it right in front of
you and you go okay gotta do this and
there's an accountability that starts to
work in your brain that's really
powerful and then you tell people you're
doing it and they're like cheering you
on you're like i can't let them down
yeah i mean even on my vision board i
wrote like a blank check and to my fed
loan with the amount to pay off and it's
crazy that now it's finally done so
george
she has a vision board yes
she has a vision board that's like a
life hack that's amazing yeah yeah you
need it really good you don't need to
manifest it when you just write it down
and go i'm going to write this check one
day and it's going to feel so good to
have no payments in the world
i love it how does it feel it feels
great it feels great to be finally free
to have no one calling me i mean i did
work another i worked two jobs at my
full-time job and i worked part-time at
amazon as a personal shopper i'm
listening to your show during cove and
you're like hey get a part-time job
while you can so i did that and it
helped me a lot how much did they pay
you for that they're paying me about i
think about 15 an hour wow that's rowdy
yeah and you made your own hours
all remote and you just check and check
out um no so i worked i worked in the
store so i was like literally literally
in the store oh wow yeah
oh my gosh so physically amazon did
something physical it was amazing except
the liver yeah this is an amazon store
no so it was amazon with whole foods so
you i would walk in like at four in the
morning and i would like pick up
groceries for people and they would i've
been known to do that the amazon whole
foods delivery dave you have two hour
delivery you can't beat that yeah and it
was free at the time george you know
we're we're a generation of convenience
dave george that's i know you went up
such a millennial dave went uphill both
ways he's not only shopped at whole
foods but i had them deliver it george
it's even more it doesn't even puke to a
dinosaur i'm sure rachel would do that
i'm sure rachel has done that
like today yeah for sure there's no
question
well that's awesome you were willing to
do whatever it took to get this thing
done well done proud of you thank you
how do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is um consistency
and having that discipline and the key
is like i said making uh writing a
vision making it plain yeah work at
whole foods instead of buy at whole
foods there you go
she got paid to be inside of a whole
foods yeah that's historic
yeah and walk out without buying
anything hello yeah whole paycheck
that's the place yeah okay wow good for
you i'm so proud of you all right we got
a copy of baby steps millionaires for
you that's the next chapter in your
story for sure you are definitely on
your way that's the next thing for the
vision board yes right millionaires on
your way gang on game on game on game on
i love it very cool also copy a total
money makeover for you to give to your
friend who doesn't think she can do it
so maybe we can gang up on her and help
her do it
in a good way so good stuff
very very cool courtney you're a rock
star you're amazing we're so proud of
you thank you very well done all right
courtney from houston texas 114
paid off in two and a half years 30 long
short months making 74 to 90 with the
extra job count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one i'm debt free
wow
reminds me the henry ford quote if you
think you can you think you can't you're
right you're right and she thought she
could and she was right
i don't know what happens in the human
spirit
or in the human brain when you write
something down
that means a lot to you not just
generally writing something down you go
okay i am going to lose
30 pounds in 90 days and you write it
out
as soon as you write it down something
snaps
i'm going to increase my income to 100
000 this year as soon as you write it
out and you actually believe it what you
can you know what you believe can
conceive and believe you can achieve
earl nightingale you should say
something happens it's not magic and
it's not it's not just the power of
positive thinking but there's something
about when you when your brain the
neural pathways when you get really
precise and concise and say this is my
desired future and then you your brain
automatically kicks into gear okay what
have i got to do to make that happen
it's a mix of science and spirit yeah a
little bit of both there a little
psychology a little brain magic but then
also it changes your spirit and you go
okay i'm gonna do this it's for real
this time i'm not playing around and
that's exactly what courtney did yeah
she's she's powerful and you know she's
quoting a scripture from the old
testament habakkuk there back at 3 3 i
believe it is it says write the vision
and make it plain
and so take your vision write it out and
this is not again not hocus pocus and
it's not just goal setting is magical
it's not it's not magical unless you go
do the work to cause the thing to happen
i mean if you write down i'm gonna lose
30 pounds and then you eat a bag of
cookies 20 minutes later probably not on
track right so well before i get started
you know no no
so um it's a cat i don't know anybody's
done that but um i could probably do it
yeah so uh you gotta write this out
and
something happens there's something your
brain just goes
and it starts focusing and all the
distractions out here the things that
were causing you to to bounce off the
walls and not hit your goals they start
to be minimized and the things that
cause you to hit your goals start to be
maximized there's something about it
yeah and so that and really you know
what a budget is
it's it's written goals yeah written
goals for the month that's all it is you
think you're going to pay off sallie mae
for the rest of your life you're
probably right and if you think you're
gonna pay her off in two years you're
probably right it's amazing how that
works yep because you will find your way
at four a.m
into a whole foods to pack groceries
that's right this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so if you want to come on
the ramsey show in person here in the
lobby you want to visit the lobby come
visit anytime by the way sidebar
it's here in nashville our visitor
center is pretty stinking incredible all
kinds of timelines and wonderful things
you can enjoy the whole ramsay
experience here uh free homemade cookies
oh my gosh
and coffee and all kinds of stuff in our
snack bar we got a big bookstore area
and you can sit and watch the show if
you'd like it's taped in the afternoons
not taped it's live in the afternoons
and is also taped while we're doing it
live
from 1 to 4 central time so if you're in
the nashville area put us on your stop
we're a little bit south of nashville in
a wonderful town called franklin
tennessee now if you want to do your
debt free scream on the phone you can do
that a lot of people do and but these
days a lot of people go oh the way i'm
going to celebrate debt freedom is i'm
gonna make a trip to nashville because
it's a cool city and i want to see the
city and i'm going to use this dave
thing isn't it this ramsay thing is an
excuse for doing that so if you want to
do that you go george you need to go the
website and fill out what's going on so
what do you ramsay solutions.com
debt free screen will take you straight
to the form to apply okay now the idea
of the debt free stream
is two things one is it is a chance for
you to celebrate
the
transformation that has occurred in your
life
and in the life of your family and we
want to celebrate that milestone with
you
also
we the the benefit of that is there's
probably a thousand or more now posted
on our youtube channel we put all the
all the debt free screams on the youtube
channel and so you can just sit and
watch them for days
uh but there's your debt-free scream is
to motivate others to tell other people
that this can
be
done now
this when we say this george that's an
important qualification what is this
this is to become debt free and stay
debt free yes
and so you've got to follow the plan to
a t and still be following it
to this day
which means
maybe you're not using a credit card
anymore not maybe it means you're not
using a credit card anymore and so here
let me help you with this kelly just
told us at the break and we were just
flabbergasted that like uh one out of
three or so of you that apply to do your
debt free stream are still using credit
cards
let me tell you what happens
we throw you in the trash bin in the
digital we don't want to motivate other
people to be like you
we want to motivate people to be not
like you
and so um that's the whole thing get out
of debt stay out of debt you're not
using your stinking credit cards anymore
and you're not violating six other
things we teach around here you know uh
every day because that's not consistent
with we're trying to create a a
transformed life here not just a simple
number that you paid off the debt and
then you're you know you're going to go
back in yeah the debt free screams are
not for those that are dave ish that's
fine
yeah it's fine if you did that but we
want to assist
we want to celebrate the people who
really made the sacrifices who had that
full 180 life transformation so there's
a series of questions when you go fill
out the form at
ramseysolutions.com and some of those
questions uh involve your financial
habits and so make sure that you answer
those honestly first of all don't skirt
around the process kelly will sniff you
out but we get thousands of applications
every year and you have to get quite a
line to do your debt free stream and a
lot of people wanting to do instead of
actually doing this stuff so we tell
people to apply months ahead of their
debt free date because there's such a
long line ahead of you but you're going
to get thrown out if you don't do it the
right way and like kelly mentioned 40
percent of you
said i'm using a credit card still
and which means hey more room for the
other sixty percent yeah i'll follow the
plan and here's the thing it'll it'll
save you a lot of time to just not even
fill out the application because you're
not gonna be on okay
and well dave i don't like that well
then get your own radio show this is
mine
so um and i get to do what i want it
says ramsay on it haha isn't that magic
so um it's not fair
yeah that's it
so you can do your own debt free stream
on your own youtube channel yeah that
works too make it up just just jump out
there and all six of your followers and
they can they can see you do it so
um but if you want to do it here we're
going to celebrate the proper kind of
life transformation that sticks and that
is generational and everything's going
through so no credit card use and uh you
know don't be issuing the stuff we talk
about don't because we don't want to let
we don't want to lift that up that's not
what we want to encourage people to be
it's not that we're mad at you well
you're just being snobbish no we have a
very
dialed in purpose for this it's to
motivate people to do
things that
we teach and have taught for 30 years
because they work because they're good
for you
um it's you know
and it's kind of unsatisfying for us to
sit and watch you half do stuff so we
don't want to do that but dave we're
missing out on the debt-free screams
where they go dave the way i got debt
free was my credit card points yeah
that's how i did it i missed that i
borrowed from the 401k dave that's how i
got debt-free yeah i borrowed my way out
of that that's how i got debt free yeah
this is these all these things come up
believe it or not so there's some
clarification for you
and um
kelly is
world renowned for being able to figure
out if you're lying or not
um she's like it's like scary she's got
a pretty good bs meter
she's looking at me right now i think i
failed
[Laughter]
ramsay solutions.com you're a little
intimidated are you okay good that's
good all right chris is with us
cleveland ohio hi chris what's up
hi dave thanks for taking my call i'll
try to be as brief as possible
my question is my wife and i over the
last two and a half years have really
focused in on the steps
and have been in the situation where now
we financially were able to pay off the
house
uh last fall
we have no credit card debt
um and it seems to me at this point
where our income levels are she had
recently gotten promoted about two years
ago
that now we're getting just absolutely
at the end of the year crushed and
having to write big checks for taxes
and i guess my question is i mean is is
potentially looking into
an llc with some rental properties even
something that should be on the table to
even look at
well an llc doesn't change the taxes at
all you can own the rental property in
your personal name
yeah tax wise it doesn't change the
taxes one bit protection wise it's good
to put rental property in there from a
risk management standpoint somebody
falls and breaks their face on that
property then they can sue only the
owner of that property which happens to
not be you have to be an llc so they
don't come take your personal vehicle so
from a risk management standpoint i no
longer own anything
i'm completely poor
a company that i own owns everything you
know so i've got this stack of llc's
it's ridiculous my cars are even owned
by llc's now so um but that's just
because you know i'm now i'm at a point
that i'm a target for lawsuits
uh because it's like oh dave ramsey
bumped into my car
you know so it's easier than winning the
lottery
who needed a job so um anyway but you're
not gonna quite be that way with one
rental property of course we're gonna
tell you to pay cash for the rental
property or not buy it and don't do
things that don't make economic sense
only for tax reasons
okay and uh if you get tired of paying
taxes and mad about paying taxes like i
have and like you are
you can go that way
and i have found myself tempted to enter
into things that really don't make any
sense except the fact that they are a
huge tax write-off
and so i i don't do i would rather just
give it a charity and then you can write
it off
you know then i would go lose it and do
something bogus that gets me in a bind
later
in order to get a write-off so as long
as you're paying cash for the rental um
yeah throw it in an llc for risk
management doesn't change taxes same
depreciation schedule either way it's
all passed through on an llc it still
lands on your personal return doesn't
change the stinking thing as far as that
goes but yeah it's okay to start talking
about doing that and it is one of the
benefits of owning some real estate and
i'd talk with a tax pro if you don't
have one already you can jump onto
ramseysolutions.com but working with one
of those elps they can look at your
whole situation and go oh here's a spot
you missed here's a spot we can save you
on taxes here's how to lower your
taxable income so that could help if
you're not already working with a pro
yeah and this idea that the rich don't
pay taxes
um
is 98 hogwash
i pay so much in taxes i can't breathe
i pay more in taxes
in a year than i made in the first 10
years of my working life wow i mean so
the idea that rich don't pay taxes
absolutely and i'm really good at this
stuff so it's just asinine that you know
well warren buffett's secretary pays at
a higher rate than he does yeah he lives
off capital gains which is a 15 rate
but it's 15 of a billion
and he's not he does the only thing he
has are investments he has no earned
income only investments
so at a higher rate yes but his
secretary doesn't have a billion dollars
that she's living off of
and so she's paying ordinary income so
that's just a bogus argument too well
that's not fair yeah it's absolutely
fair it's the tax code
sorry boys and girls it's the law
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host you jump in
we'll talk about your life and your
money it's a free call at aaa 825-5225
george camel ramsey personality host of
the entree leadership podcast the fine
print podcast and many other things
around ramsey is my co-host as we answer
your questions we help people build
wealth do work that they love
and create real
high quality relationships it's your
life and it's right here on the radio
ray is with us ray is in cincinnati hi
ray welcome to the show
thanks uh thanks for taking my call guys
sure what's up my question is that
i'm looking for the best way to purchase
a family farm from a trust
my in-law offered to sell us the farm at
about half its value because he just uh
no longer can really maintain it he
wants to make sure he can uh he'd like
to see something done with it why you
have the ability to make the decisions
uh why he said his health
i said it's already in a family trust
where my wife and uh four kids make up
half the trustees and it's like a dream
opportunity but
we have about 90 000 left on our current
mortgage and we're hoping that in about
two and a half years we were going to be
completely debt-free
but it's a dream for us to have the farm
so we didn't know any ideas how to uh
make this happen any
special transfers or anything we can do
just trying to come up with a way to
make this happen okay who owns
who has the beneficial interest in the
trust who's the owner of the farm today
not your wife just this one-in-law
yes
okay so this one person is going to be
the only benefit
correct okay and what are they selling
it to you for what is the dollar amount
uh 300 000 it will be about half the
actual value
what is your i heard that part earlier
what is your house worth
i would say probably four hundred
thousand
and you know ninety you can can you not
live on the farm
uh well uh sorry i left that part out
they would love to stay they want to
stay on the farm until they pass
so and no the farmhouse is not big
enough to hold our family
they live in the farmhouse now
correct how many acres is the farm
uh roughly 90 acres would you farm it
well it's cash lease right now and that
farm income covers the taxes and
insurance and i would continue to do
that and then have some recreational
property there also
so when the person passes what will
happen to the farmhouse will you live in
it
uh
at that point we don't know if it would
be uh you know would you build on
another portion of the farm
i don't believe so
i'm confused right this doesn't even
make sense you're saying this is your
dream but it also has no feasibility for
your family to live there
well it's uh just the location the
recreation the uh
owning the dirt is the dream not living
on it correct okay
all right
um
well
here's what i think about doing all
right
i think about carving out one acre
around the house that the person who
wants to live in give them a life estate
to that house and one acre not to the
entire property
okay i would sell your house
and move into a rental and buy this
property
now you own it
okay
then you've got two options one is start
saving like crazy for a good strong down
payment on a house
or
uh start talking about building on this
property and getting a construction loan
to do that
how far is it from your work
uh 30 miles how far are you from your
work
now 25
no no no okay that's a break even
so i'm going to challenge you to find a
corner of the property not right square
in the middle of the stinking thing and
look for a building site
all right okay so really then you're
you're gonna you're you're only going to
be in debt what it takes to build a
house because you're going to pay cash
for the property when you sell your
property
yes
okay how old is the people living in the
farmhouse
uh late 70s
do you want to rent until they leave
no okay probably not okay
so what i'm do what i'm saying is okay
how big
here's your trade-off okay i always look
at things that are
trade off like one hand two hands right
the the old tipping of the scales kind
of a thing if you visualize the scales
of justice a little bit okay you want to
own this how bad do you want to own it
how much inconvenience are you willing
to go to to get to own it and do it in a
wise way paying cash for it from the
sale of your property sounds okay
that leaves you homeless however and we
got to figure out a place for you to
park right
yes and so the trade-off is do you go
into debt to build you a house and put
it on a 15-year fixed or less and build
you a pretty nice property equal to the
one you've got now in the corner of the
farm somewhere leaving the rest of it
open for farming and recreation uh
you've maybe turned the little uh
little farmhouse into a rental when the
people pass the uncle passes or whatever
or you just go rent and start piling up
some cash and reassess your options but
now your dream is so are you willing to
on the the negative side to rent or be
inconvenienced in order to live this
dream or you want your cake and eat it
too if you want your cake and eat it too
you're going to break yourself you don't
have enough money
yeah the thing is that
when they pass my wife and the kids
become 50 owners in it at that point
anyway but then i think things get messy
and that's what i tend to worry about i
agree go ahead and close on it i'd sell
the one you live in i'd do the deal okay
you can buy a 600 000 property for 300
000 and basically they're advancing you
her half
is what they're doing they're not really
discounting it they're just advancing
you her half
and then and okay but you own the dirt
and then i'm gonna figure out some way
to live on that dirt if i'm you
and how desperate do you want to be on
that i mean
people have done some crazy things that
i wouldn't do that have called this show
like rolla
roll a uh
uh a trailer you know a 5000 r trailer
up on there and park it or something i
i'm not living in that but because i'm a
snob
but um
but you know you figure out what you're
coming out of a 400 000 house so i'm not
making that as a viable suggestion okay
but what would ramses do uh i like dirt
you know
i got a 250 acre farm just over the hill
over here is one of my favorite places
on the planet
and so i'm i believe in owning some dirt
to keep the planet held together we
don't want it to come apart or anything
so
and and i like this it's in the family
you get you got you you like it it's in
your wife's family it's pretty cool i
think it's got a cool vibe on the thing
but don't go over there and go 300 000
in debt keep your 400 000 house and then
try to figure out why you're broke
because we will all know multiple
mortgages because you have this dream
yeah we will all know why you're broke
because you did stupid butt stuff
because you got all caught up in the
dream of this thing and thought it was
all just going to work out it ain't
gonna work out you gotta make it work
out dude you gotta force it through the
mold
and uh that means you put stuff on the
other side of the scales the
inconvenient bad stuff living in a
rental building
waiting
something uncomfortable in order to make
this happen today and keep the messiness
of family out of it later this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
george do you realize we're gonna get to
do a live event in about a week not
virtual not virtual real people it's
like humans it's virtual means sort of
conduct yeah we're not sort of kind of
doing it we're really freaking doing it
game on human beings and it's going to
be about 2 000 of us there in las vegas
we'll be there may the 5th that is next
thursday for most of you and uh we are
looking forward to being there we're
going to be doing one of our
building wealth live events uh we're
doing them all over the nation this
spring and fall rachel cruz george
campbell and i and we're adding dr john
dolone and king coleman that's nice into
the mix
and i'll be discussing things that are
going on in america right now
things that are people are talking about
and how do you really build wealth in
this current environment in this current
situation
las vegas is next week may 5th two weeks
later orlando on may the 19th
and that's followed by the entree
leadership summit the following week
there in orlando we'll be down there for
four days doing that that's going to be
about 3 000 folks small business leaders
from all over america a lot of fun and
then in the fall we will be doing
sacramento november the 1st
minneapolis november the 10th san
antonio november the 15th and we'll be
adding one more city very soon the
mystery will be unv bailed i heard today
the contract is coming in i didn't even
know so this is news time to get the
venues under contract these days before
we can actually start talking about them
because well people are just weird plans
change so there you go yeah
yeah and on top of that smart conference
october 22nd in dallas that's right so
we've got a whole bunch of events all
over the place george we're gonna get
some work out of you that's what i'm
getting some miles too so what i'm
saying crack the whip tickets are 25
each for these building wealth live
events a four pack however you can get
bring it up you know one of you couples
bring another couple with you that are
friends y'all make a great night of it
you're going to be entertained you're
going to leave inspired you're going to
know what to do to build wealth you're
not going to be under any illusions of
any get rich quick stuff or anything
like that 60 for a four pack that's only
15 bucks a piece you can't buy a pizza
for that so come out
we would love to have you again
vegas there's a few tickets left for
next week if you want to come orlando
just a couple you better get them quick
let me know may they're just about sold
out for here in may may 5th may 19th and
the ones for next fall are already over
half sold out wow and so don't wait
around i'm going to get out i wish i'd
gotten my ticket really they're not that
expensive go get them my goodness
gracious ramsay solutions.com events is
the place to go that's exactly right
thanks for that reminder blinds.com is
our question of the day find out for
yourself why blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings
free samples
free shipping
new promos all the time you save money
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best deal it's magic today's question
comes from davin in florida i'm a 45
year old single dad who has been
financially irresponsible for most of my
life
two years ago i became a full-time
firefighter with great benefits now i
have a deferred compensation plan saved
religiously towards my son's prepaid
college expenses and i'm putting 120
dollars a month into an index fund my
monthly expenses are my mortgage living
expenses 600 child support and a 200
chapter 13 bankruptcy payment i'm
hesitant about stopping my current
investments and my son's prepaid college
to pay off the 10 000 of chapter 13 debt
only because i've started so late in the
game i have no other debt should i
continue on the course i'm on or should
i stop all retirement investments and
put it towards the bankruptcy debt
what an interesting predicament he's
found himself in
well i don't see this any different than
a different type of debt i'm putting
this in the debt snowball i'm pausing
all investments and i'm going
gangbusters to get rid of this debt
really fast yeah yeah
davin or daven however you pronounce it
the
truth is when you get the debts paid off
and you're out from under the chapter 13
bankruptcy
that's going to put your
financial irresponsibility and the shame
associated with it in the rear view
mirror
today
you get a monthly reminder
it's like i have to write i was a i used
to be stupid check
every month
you don't want to keep doing that you
want that in your rearview mirror
where
grace belongs
and look out the windshield towards a
beautiful bright future
what little
ground you lose by stopping temporarily
you're investing while you clear up the
debt you will be able to make up very
quickly
and i will tell you that some of the
most successful people following our
plans
are first responders
firemen in most areas the way their
schedules are put together have
a an unbelievably
fabulous opportunity for side hustle
and a lot of them make more on their
side hustles than they do or as much as
they do being a firefighter
and um
so i know a bunch of them that build
decks and paint houses and do all kinds
of stuff got great side businesses in
their off days because you're you know
you're off half the time
uh and then when you're on you're on
completely so
uh you did say you're single dad so i
don't know what that entails here in
terms of being able to do the side
hustle but
uh all of that to say there's something
spiritually emotionally psychologically
uh
significant about putting that
bankruptcy in your rear view mirror plus
you're getting out of debt
so let's let's yeah georgia's exactly
that'll increase your cash flow on top
of that on top of the spirit part
mathematically you'll be able to do all
your stuff triple the money to invest
instead of 100 bucks and by the way i
wouldn't do prepaid college ever
i'd do a 529 in good mutual funds
uh you don't want to pre-pay a college
because you might not go there
and you might not go in that state and i
don't know how they've got it set up and
when you prepay something your rate of
return
on what you have prepaid is the
inflation rate of the item
college has traditionally been a seven
percent seven point two percent over the
last fifty years is the inflation rate
on tuition
and so you're making seven percent on
your money instead of 10 or 12 a good
mutual fund
and so you should be in a 529 good
mutual funds not in a prepaid college
anyway
and on top of that some of the states
that you people are paying into your
prepaid on they are awful with money
like illinois
sound like that illinois yeah but um
yeah horrible horrible financial
condition and i don't really want to
park my money with this institution that
is completely out of control
so no don't do that
good question shelby's in fort worth
texas hi shelby welcome to the ramsey
show
hi dave and george thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
hey so i just got an opportunity to um
have a company car
and so now i'm wondering what to do with
my personal car i've got about thirty
four thousand watson student loans and
some kind of employment to sell
can you drive the company car for
personal use
yes i can
why would you keep the other car then
sell it
my concern is um if the company car has
to go in for any type of like longer
maintenance i i mean i drive the car
throughout um you know the city to
different jobs and homes and so if i
don't have a car to drive personally
then the company tells you to put their
car in for maintenance they don't give
you a replacement
that is a good question i don't know i
just got it that would be normal by the
way and how often is this going in for
maintenance
well
i mean i just got it so it's a little
older with over a hundred thousand miles
so it may be a little more frequent um
but
the company gave you a company car with
a hundred thousand miles on it
i'm in home health so it racks up easily
wow
so you're putting a lot of miles on a
car
yes okay and my can you end right now is
really long um it's about an hour
commute the dot will be decreasing in
the summer okay
i'd sell it for top dollar your current
car
and use that thing okay how big is your
company
um you are pretty big over the state
i'm sorry
they're pretty big all over the state
yeah okay because they just it's they
cheaped out on the car and i was just
curious why
oh i mean i don't i don't know it was it
was not supposed to be a permanent thing
i was just supposed to have it for a
couple months and then it kind of turned
into a long-term thing so i mean i don't
know how long they typically keep their
cards it could be at the end of its
cycle
okay all right and
yeah i would get rid of it you don't
have any reason to pay bills on a car
sitting in your driveway you can get you
if all the whole deal falls apart for
whatever reason go get another car if
the car goes in for extended maintenance
rent a car for a short period of time
all of that will be cheaper than owning
a car that's sitting in your driveway
paying tax and insurance and
in general the thing's going down in
value it hasn't lately but in general it
is so yeah i'm getting rid of it
thanks for the call
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
george camel ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on the debt free stage drc and alan are
with us hey guys how are you hi hi dave
hi we're excited to meet you both well
you too where do you guys live
we're in st augustine florida oh
beautiful area very cool welcome to
nashville and all the way here to do a
debt-free scream how much did you pay
off
three hundred and six thousand
five hundred and eighty six dollars and
sixty six cents
might be the nerd love it that might be
it might be yeah and how long did this
take this took 42 months okay and your
range of income during that time we
started at 194 000 and went up to 247
000. wow very cool what do y'all do for
a living i'm a pharmacist and i'm a
painting contractor very good good okay
was what kind of debt was this was this
the house
no no no no it's from a it was from a
failed business
from a failed business yeah okay tell us
the story what happened yes so actually
this is the second time we've gone
through um your baby steps so we had
completely paid off everything including
the house in 2017
and we apparently
did not learn our lesson hard enough
we thought a business was different so
we ended up um getting some business
loans and and uh doing a business that
that ended up a failing in about a year
and a half which is when you find out
that business is not different yes this
is not different and you need to listen
to your uncle dave
is debt his debt is debt yes so what
kind of business was it yes it was a
hormone weight loss business okay and
what happened what caused it to fail
well we had it was a brick and mortar so
i would first advise nobody to do brick
and mortar if you can at all help it
and to um like we really had a marketing
um issue so lots of expense and then it
was hard getting people in the door so
okay not enough customers
um no so this is all the business debt
that we we paid off so we still have the
house left but we are keeping our
expenses very very low so it's very very
manageable we should be able to have
that
right now the house is the only debt
that we have right okay and so what was
this like sba loans or
um
no we had taken like the equity from a
house that we had paid off and used a
lot of that and then on top of that we
were we were trying to support the
marketing so we were getting a bunch of
different um loans and credit cards for
that so okay yeah cool
so the thing crashes you close it up
and then you go okay now i got to clean
this up yes
and that was 42 months ago yes yes wow
so we were that's a hard debt to pay off
emotionally yeah i mean it's one thing
to go buy something stupid at the store
and then have that on a credit card but
the the failed business breaks your
heart yes and you know it just makes you
beat yourself up and now i got to pay
payments on it oh my gosh it's like a
it's like paying alimony it's awful it's
on the old marriage you know it's like
ugh absolutely it was like one of the
darkest times of life that i've ever
been through and uh you know i just
we're so
grateful that you know we were able to
do it together and walk through it
together and and kind of make progress
forward and and
just
just grateful to be out of that dark
place
well you guys you guys did a lot of
hustling and grinding okay and so the
business closed um were one of you
already were you you're already a
pharmacist i'm sure
okay and were you already doing painting
yes okay so you just took those and made
them the full-time gig and beefed it up
and went on yes
okay all right and then just roll up
your sleeves you get after it yes yes
yes just we had a huge xl
sheet of all the little things and just
took them one by one through the
snowball i i give your debt snowball app
a workout
throwing snowballs what is there for
that's awesome yes so what was the
hardest part for you guys i mean 42
months is a long time and that's a whole
big pile of debt
was the hardest part i think just the
emotional part of it
you know a lot of a lot of self-doubt
and
you know pain yeah sleep sleepless
nights and just wondering if you know
can we can we really do this like can we
get through it and um
yeah i mean
god god willing we we were and we had we
had a lot of support
yeah
well
as dark as it is too
as you start approaching the light at
the end of it it gets really really
super exciting because it's like i'm
just about done with this crap right i
mean i remember this i remember this
exact set of emotions yeah every every
two weeks our our daughter would help us
with the little chart that we had going
so she'd take out her little pink
highlighter and help us along so it was
it was so satisfying as you see the
depth snowball grow and you see you're
making these like huge chunks on your
debt you know what you never thought
were possible and so now we're seeing
the glimmer you know on the horizon and
we see how we can flip it and then you
know that's going to be start to be our
savings and and really make some major
progress here in the next couple years
most of us that have closed a small
business though experienced a certain
amount if not a lot of shame
for the goof up that is associated with
it and the further you got down the debt
snowball the more that was in your rear
view mirror the thing i experienced was
i was more and more and more free of not
just the debt and the the arithmetic but
that shame was further back there it's
like oh that's back there that's back
there i'm not that guy anymore i learned
it i got it it's back there last little
bit i gotta sweep up this one more
corner and we're done yes but what was
it hard was even preparing for today we
were putting together our little like
placard of saying how much we paid off
and and just looking at the number i
mean i know
you know i know the number because i'm
the nerd but just looking at the number
on the placard of how much we paid off
is like oh it just you know hits you in
the gut and it's done but it's done it
is done and the stun is finished we're
here this is our celebration again never
again again never again for anything for
anything yeah you never get yeah it's
this lesson is now seared that was a hot
stove with a lot of zeros at the end of
it yes yes wow well you guys are
inspiring and you said you had a lot of
support who are your biggest
cheerleaders oh so so many support so
many people like really really helped us
we um
we
did go through financial peace
university
a couple different times and are so glad
for all of the sets of families that
that went through that with us we
actually
co-led it and we co-led it at numa life
church so just want to give a shout out
to our church and also to our ramsay
preferred coach heather seymour who has
been along for for the ride with us she
really helped us especially with the
business finances
and getting that dialed in and the debt
there so we can the point she actually
comes up here and does the debt free
screen with you yes that's ultimate
support right there
absolutely and i i also want to thank um
a close friend of mine chris larson for
all the support he gave me yeah yeah
you got to have friends in your corner
when you're going through this
it's a big deal
i mean it's a big deal what you all been
through is is incredible i'm proud of
you for work walking through it because
it's a tough tough slog
uh getting out of that's one thing
getting out of this kind of debt in this
situation with all the emotions and
things around it it's um it's a big deal
very well done very very very well done
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is now you've been
through from the fpu a couple times and
now you did the hard stuff what do you
tell them oh well i was going to say the
the biggest thing that i learned from
going through this is from
my wife and i getting on the same page
and um you know just coming to an
agreement with every decision that we
made
and you know we haven't had enough even
going through all of this we haven't had
a fight
over finances since 2009.
that's a big deal yeah because all along
together we made the financial decisions
like it had to be like two thumbs up or
we weren't doing it so we were in it
together and we fought through it
together and you know having your steps
to really have a framework of like okay
this is how we're gonna do it we're
gonna agree on this framework and we're
going to solution and move forward
love it well done we got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you that's the
next chapter you're on your way
i love it and a copy of total money
makeover for you to give away to
somebody in your fpu group or somebody
you want to stir up a ruckus with i love
it and have to say hello to genevieve
and campbell our kids that are at home
very cool
all right drc and allen saint augustine
florida 307 000 paid off in 42 months
making 199 to 247. count it down let's
hear a debt free scream
three two
[Applause]
one felt that one deep down yeah wow
real
real stuff going on there never gets old
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
eight two five five
two two five
jeanette is in savannah georgia hi
jeanette how are you
hi i'm good thank you so much for taking
my call sure what's up
so
my husband and i i'm kind of caught
between my husband and my grandmother
and i love them both so much and i want
to love them well i'm hoping you can
give me some advice
we've been married for about a year
we're debt-free except for our mortgage
our household incomes about ninety
thousand a year we both worked a billion
hours overtime
and i've been financially supporting my
grandparents since before we got married
and we agreed that i'd continue to do
that for them because they're on a very
fixed income
and that comes out to about 700 a month
that i helped to pay their rent
when my grandfather passed away very
suddenly in june of last year
her income of course took a big hit
because now there's just her social
security
the plan was that when the lease was up
in july
that she would move in with us to save
money and she's in the process of
selling
a piece of commercial property that's
her only asset and we're going to use
that money to buy her a permanent house
that she can live in with no payment
well she told me yesterday that she's
just not emotionally ready to move it
hurts too much even for her to look at
my grandfather's things much less
pack them up and come stay with us with
nothing in her hand but a suitcase
and she wants me to extend the lease for
her
my husband wants what's best for all of
us
financially especially because we're
expecting our first baby in july as well
um and he's pretty adamant that giving
money to a rental company is
a waste when she can live with us for
you know just temporarily
and i'm i'm kind of he's correct 100
mathematically
but then i've also got the emotional
side of the equation from her and i'm
desperately looking for a third option
do you think that i should
extend the lease for her or try to
convince her to stay with us or maybe
just extend the lease for a few months
to give the property time to sell
i i just
just don't know what would be the wise
decision here
[Music]
i'm sorry that's a hard place to be
i mean it is it sure is and how
supportive and hard-working
she's in her mid-seventies
how long has she lived in this rental
um about two years i used to live she
used to live there with me before i got
married and moved out and they continued
to live there after i got married
does she attend a local church
she does she is very active in her in
her local church and she has friends to
support her and everything but it's
you know they they were married for yeah
you know over 30 years i can't imagine
what she's going through and my heart's
broken for her but at the same time
i want all of us to be okay
well
um
i'm it's just sad
uh the thing is is her staying in this
house for a few more months is not going
to mean her heart is not broken
her 30-year best friend is gone her
heart's just broken
and she's confusing that
that this house location
which isn't a human thing by the way
there's nothing wrong she's not doing
anything wrong but um
the truth is is that um
she's going to have she's going to deal
with the grief of this situation in a
location and a rental house she's been
in for two years
doesn't enter into the emotional part of
it it's just she's she's just wishing
that this wasn't the story
and i can pretend i can put my hands
over my ears and go la la la la la this
story is not happening if i can just
stay in this house
and so it's it's kind of a form of
denial if you will i think
do you think i'm wrong
you know i i i think you're right i
think she's just having a really hard
time
i would have a little more i would i
would i would agree with her a little
bit more if she'd lived in this house
for 30 years
you know
but it's been there two years
and so to associate that with him being
gone
is not as logical does that mean is that
a lot do you see what i'm saying
yeah and i i get that she's hurting i i
i'm not i don't want to diminish that
and i don't think the way you've
presented this that your husband is
diminishing that
i think he's just going look
we've all got to deal with this and it's
just there's no good
ending to this story because pop you
know grandpa's just gone i mean and he's
just gone to heaven and so it you know
it's just gonna hurt
whatever we do is gonna hurt
and so um
and how long ago did he pass again
um almost a year in june last year
it feels like on top of the you know on
top of the emotions he's looking at the
facts going well this is she's broke and
so without you she doesn't have any
options
and so at that point i go okay she lives
with us for a little bit and then we you
sell this commercial property she
processes through the grief as much as
she can and maybe you can give her some
tools to do that but either way she's
gonna have to get out of this thing
because you can't fund her life forever
you know i
i think that you're on you know
you've got a good plan overall um
and um
while i my heart breaks for your your
grandma i think your husband's probably
right not from a math standpoint but
even from just loving your grandmother
well standpoint
because she just needs some people to
grieve with and you being there for and
a new baby in the house and all that
kind of stuff it's a that's a good place
for her to kind of heal and spend time
with
you know and living in this rental house
with the the past all around her just
isolated is not that doesn't facilitate
her
going through the hurt and the pain of
this it doesn't facilitate her going
through the grieving process
so i probably the reason i ask about the
church is if she respects her pastor
i'd probably you know the two of you sit
are the you and your husband and grandma
sit down with pastor
and let pastor you know kind of
be the spiritual guide and maybe he even
takes some of the lumps instead of your
husband taking them because maybe he
suggests
that she go ahead and get out of there
and get moved
because i think that's what's best for
her
not now you know it also happens to be
what's best for y'all but i think it's
what's best for her
because her reasoning for staying there
is to say i'm going to pretend like this
didn't happen i want to live in the past
a little while longer that's going to
make me not hurt and not walk through
the process of the grief here and i want
her to
to
uh dr dalonio he says grief demands a
witness and so when he's got she's got
you and your husband and the new baby
and she's right there and
and um
you know she's not lonely she's not
sitting there in that rental house by
herself watching some stupid television
thing you know
you know what i'm saying i think it's
just best for her
okay
and i i knew that i know that you're
right i know that he's right it's just
it's so hard for me to watch her cry you
know so
well my point is she's really not crying
about a rental house
yeah she's really crying because
grandpa's gone
yeah and that's okay she's supposed to
cry
i mean i've been married 40 years um we
plan on me dying before sharon because i
won't do well without her
it's a it's part of the estate plan i
pre-deceased her i mean it's just it's
the way we've arranged it
as long as no more details about how
that's going to go then it gets
don't ask about sharon's plans okay but
yeah
well jeannette i'd love to send you a
copy of john dolone's new book on your
past change your future i'm hoping it
gives you some tools maybe some tools
for grandma maybe you guys can go
through it together i don't know what
that looks like for you but we'll have
kelly pick up and send you guys a copy
because i think that can give her some
tools some resources to process through
this very very difficult thing yeah i i
do think the pastor with his arm around
her
and you and your husband sitting there
and y'all praying and her crying
through this decision
is probably going to help her
and i don't want the end of this story
to be your husband ends up being the bad
guy to grandma or to you
either one because he's not
and uh he you did not describe him as
belligerent or greedy or this is not
about money
and then just thinking it through it
with you here on the air it really does
appear to us that it's really what's
best for her
emotionally
psychologically oh and the finances also
happen to line up
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
this is the show where we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create real
and amazing relationships george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host this hour this is a baby steps
millionaire theme hour thank you for
joining us america we're so glad you're
here we're going to be talking with real
millionaires this year people who really
are millionaires not your broke
brother-in-law with an opinion we're
asking how you really did it
what really happened
now a millionaire is not someone that
makes a million dollars a year george a
millionaire someone with a million
dollar net worth what you
own minus what you owe it's a simple
formula
equals a million dollars or more than
your millionaire
that is your net worth
there's not multiple definitions well
he's a net worth millionaire that's
redundant
there's only one type of millionaire and
that is a net worth millionaire someone
who earns an income of a million dollars
or more is not a millionaire by any
definition this is an accounting term it
is a financial planning term it is not
a societal commentary it is not a moral
construct and so you don't get to
freaking change it it's just this is
what a millionaire is and this is the
only way you get to be a millionaire you
have a million what you own minus what
you owe is in excess of a million
dollars doesn't matter if it creates an
income or not you can have a family farm
that just sits and it's just dirt and
it's worth two million dollars and
that's all you have then you're worth
two million dollars because you can sell
it for two million dollars
hypothetically so there you go so
anybody that has a million dollars we
want to talk to you this hour because we
want to find out what you did and how
you did it did you win the lottery did
you inherit the money uh are you a
famous rock star
uh did you um i don't know some other
bizarre thing that people believe that
doesn't ever really happen these are
percentage-wise never occur but if
you're any of those that's wonderful
we'd love to talk to you however you got
your million we want to hear your story
to tell people how they can do it open
phones at eight eight two five five two
two five we're talking with real
millionaires mike's gonna start us off
in california mike what's your net
worth dave thank you for having me um
we're 2.6 million oh very good okay cool
and um very good and so break that down
for me what's the mix on it
the mix is uh 1.4
and that's a combination about um 80
percent 41k and 20 roth okay so 1.4 in
retirement all right and the other uh
1.2
is the
is my home
your your home is worth 1.2
exactly i'll get that off um
two weeks ago oh good for you very good
yeah okay how old are you thanks thanks
thanks to you dave 60. 60. well i didn't
pay it you did way to go how much of the
uh uh 2.6 million that you have did you
inherit
uh zero zero okay cool
and uh what was your best year household
income since you've been working and
your worst your household incomes that
you've been working
uh 50 to
over 200k cool what you do for a living
both my wife and i are in sales she's in
food distribution and i'm in i.t cool
uh you got a four-year degree
um
high school yes
a high school degree okay cool do you
remember your gpa
3.3 and my wife was through 3.8 okay
cool good good she's just she's a smart
one no i got you yeah i understand she
picked you yeah so
[Laughter]
all right so uh
do you use an investment professional or
did you do all this yourself
oh yeah we started to uh of course you
know through our whole venture through
um at pu and
and yeah once once we went through all
that dave yes we got our
financial advisor and asset upper trust
and everything so
we've we followed your plan awesome mike
i'm curious was this a goal of yours or
did it just kind of happen
right now i've been holding a big day
fan i've been a big dave fan for 15
years i've been doing davish
so would you say this is a 15-year
journey that you've kind of set out on
intentionally well for myself and until
my wife you know jumped on board um
you know about seven years ago and
we and and it's it helps it helps the
marriage it helps communication and
we just um we just went after it and we
focus on the house and and we did it wow
very good good for you man i'm proud of
you how's it feel
awesome i mean it's this freedom
and yeah so we were thinking what are we
going to do now
and
it's it's like it's exciting to see
where we're going to move forward yes
yeah wow good for you
and i'm going to you know dave i want to
give a shout out to my wife i love her
she's she's on the road she wanted to be
here um we're just big fans and i just
wanted to tell her i love her wow that's
very cool that's the way it works man
well done rockstar couple okay now
you're 60 years old you have a 2.6
million dollar net worth you make 200
000 a year household income you live in
california
if someone's out there listening this 22
can they still do what you did
for sure
i think my my son is a good example you
know with
you know if he he knows knows the value
of a dollar and if you want to um buy
something you save for it and you buy it
it drives used cars
and image is overrated
um
yeah just live your life who cares about
whatever what anybody else thinks
um very well done hey brother we're
proud of you congratulations another
baby steps millionaire out there after
the name that's what we named the book
after was these guys just like mike and
his wife how ordinary people built
extraordinary wealth and how you can too
see the misnomer george is that everyone
inherited their wealth
that they don't deserve it that's the
biggest lie that's the biggest lie well
it also infers that if you don't have a
rich uncle you're screwed
and what mike is saying is you're not
you can do this
you can get out you can get out of debt
you can live on lesson you make you
don't worry about image and you put
money away and ta-da
but it's easier to get mad at rich
people dave than it is to do the work
that's the truth
well
it is but it's not as effective
and it doesn't get you what you want to
get and if you believe a lie you will
then function in that lie and
that's how we started doing this theme
hour is
uh and then we ended up doing the
largest study of millionaires that has
ever been done in north america over 10
167 of them studied and we asked them in
great detail what their
um
you know what their process was who they
are we found that 79 inherited precisely
zero
that five percent inherited a very small
amount like five thousand dollars from
the grandmother or something like that
and another five percent inherited good
money big money like a hundred thousand
bucks or something but after they were
already millionaires
and so that five plus five plus 79
gives you the number of 89
percent of america's millionaires are
not
that because of inheritance
it's a big deal george yeah it's because
of intentionality consistency over time
94 said they live on less than they make
it's that simple wow if you just do that
you will be wealthy
what a concept well maybe they should
run for congress
i don't think they'll make it through
live on less than you make
a concept congress can't grasp
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
so
[Music]
if you're looking to sell your house
right now it can be overwhelming but you
don't have to sell your home alone you
need an endorsed local provider by your
side our elps are ramsey trusted that
means they're highly vetted they're top
tier real estate agents that my team and
i trust they're pros who are excited to
serve you and help you sell your home at
the right price
if you're ready to get a home sold to
get with the ramsey trusted elp in your
corner and it's free to connect of
course just go to
com slash ramseysolutions.com you can
find one near you ramsay solutions dot
com slash agent it's a baby steps
millionaires theme hour my latest number
one bestselling book baby steps
millionaires how ordinary people build
extraordinary wealth how you can
too
maggie is with us in st louis hey maggie
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's your net worth
my husband and i our net worth is 1.2
million okay give me a little breakdown
on that how much retirement how much
house and so on
uh we have about
575 000 in rocks almost 100 000 in
traditional so about six to seven
hundred thousand and
retirement we have 425 000 equity on our
house
about 50 000 sitting in a savings
account and college uh savings and other
assets are about 40 000. cool how old
are you guys
we i am 39 our goal was to be
millionaires by the time we were 40 and
i met that at the end of my 37th year so
you made it amazing we made it i love it
how much of this 1.2 million did you
guys inherit
you know we did not inherit any of it in
fact when we found you in 2007 we are
575 000 in debt
whoa
yeah this is a turnaround i talked to
you i talked to you in 2007 when we
first started i called into the show was
it nice to you
no
you ended this show you ended this my
call was oh what a mess
and it wasn't a man
[Laughter]
it's been known to happen and here you
are two million dollars later it's 575
negative to 1.2 positive i love it
so what is your range of income in your
working life your best year ever in your
worst year ever
our worst year was about a hundred
thousand together our best which only
happened one year was 325.
what do you guys do what's your career
we are both pharmacists ah very good
okay explains the debt
yes it does 300 000 in debt i got it
okay
and so uh your degree is obviously in
pharmacy what was your gpa
mine was pretty high i was uh 3.9
my husband was about a 2.8 oh
whoa
just like that he still he he up yep
so they they really don't care about
that once you get into the real world
they care about your ability to work and
your hard work
did you count the pills in that bottle
correctly that's all they care about
yeah
oh my gosh incredible very well done
love it yeah so what do you tell people
can they still do this
they absolutely can do this there is
hope
um even if the dave ramsey says that
your finances are a mess but there's no
that's the best part i mean you guys had
in over 15 years you had almost a 2
million dollar turnaround what do you
attribute that to obviously you guys had
a great income but you guys are really
intentional
um yeah we were i think in the beginning
before we had kids we were living about
20 of our income and tithing 10
and then
putting 70 percent into um
trying to get out of debt was mainly um
but a good communication like i just
think you know when we started my
husband wasn't super interested in it
the only reason he want he went to a
dave ramsey class was because we were
new to the area and he wanted to meet
people but after
after listening to one the first lesson
he was hooked um but just like good
communication i think was a thing in the
ability to just
make it fun throughout the process and
have goals
and we definitely made a ton of mistakes
along the way i'm telling you i'm proud
of you guys what you've done is very
intense i mean you're millionaires by
the time you're 40 and you overcame a
575 000 debt hole very impressive so uh
the opposite end of the story the first
time i talked to you i said it what a
mess now i'm saying what a champion um i
like that what an amazing what an
amazing couple of people very well done
that's incredible very well inspiring
all right nick is with us in connecticut
hi nick uh what's your net worth
hi dave my net worth is 1.5 million cool
very good uh how old are you
uh 33. oh wow young millionaire give me
a little breakdown on that uh 1.5
between retirement house and whatever
else it's in
okay uh 1.5 uh yeah sorry 150 000 home
equity
50 000 in other equity
1 uh 150 000 in a uh an ir traditional
ira and my proud claim of
1.15 million in a roth ira
wow big roth you've been kicking it at
33 to get it to that point very good so
how much of this money did you inherit
not a dime
zero
and what's your best working year and
your worst working year
since you've been working
yeah with my wife it's about 75k and uh
lowest and highest 120. okay cool what
do y'all do what do you do for a living
i'm between jobs i'm looking to get into
banking and investing and my wife
manages a an i.t team cool you got a
four-year degree
i do not okay does she
yes and what
uh psychology
okay cool very good all right and uh
good good for you
okay so how do you do this by 33 years
old dude you loaded this thing up this
is impressive
uh honestly i got gotta get lucky like i
said i've been uh my passion's been
investing
um
i know i have to disclose that i was i
am a reformed i'm gonna self self called
degenerate um i got involved with wall
street bets hit gamestop really big got
out and i am in mutual funds and etfs
now
whoa
so you cashed the chips off the table
before you took the hit
exactly so this all happened very
recently
yeah this is in january of 2021. so what
was your net worth before that
55k oh my goodness
that's
quite the jump from 55k net worth to 1.5
million
and uh you took some risks if you had
this if you had not taken the chips off
the table you'd almost be back there
wouldn't you
something like that but yeah i know i
when the time was right getting out
getting good and putting it somewhere
safe yeah your timing your timing is
impeccable
very well done good for you man i'm
proud for you a needle in a haystack
kind of story i'm proud for you though
it's a good thing to i like talking to
somebody that did it that's good
and uh the trick because most people
don't have the uh
they get they get lured by the siren
song of the success and they stay in
and they end up riding the same horse
until it dies uh instead of getting out
at the top and you were smart enough
wise enough to get out of the top and
realizing that this is not a forever
play so well done
at least i guess that's what happened is
that what happened
yeah
january 28 uh 2021 will be the most
stressful day of my life
i had a
a million dollar loss and unrealized
gains and then the next day we sold it
at the top wow wow
amazing wow
hard to replicate wouldn't recommend it
to to our listeners but it's not a
method that works very often but it got
you got it done so that's what we we
take the calls from however you did it
and we want to hear the true story so
good for you man i'm proud of you
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five so talking to
some young millionaires today a 60 a 39
a 33 wow well everybody that's rich are
crooks greedy rich people greedy rich
people
no
i hadn't talked to any of those today
none of these people stole their money
none of them did anything illegal wow
no drug deals here
just hard work not that we're aware of
not that they're willing to tell us not
that was admitted to here on the air
yeah and we haven't talked to anybody
who had a uh number one best-selling
record yeah i said most of them hit
millionaire status at age 49 in our
study and if you took the average here i
think you'd find something similar yeah
the average isn't just 49 of those three
right very interesting we'll talk to
some more millionaires right here on a
baby steps millionaire female
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
it's a baby steps millionaires theme
hour here on the ramsey show where we
talk to real millionaires and find out
how they
really did it not so what someone's
political opinion is
or people with uh
their expertise coming from twitter
which would by definition be an oxymoron
so expertise from twitter as an auction
was the keyword [ __ ] in that sentence
it could be okay yeah there's a real key
word george campbell ramsey personality
is my co-host today open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five as we talk to millionaires rob is
in omaha nebraska rob what is your net
worth
hi dave hey george my network is 1.2
million cool give me a little breakdown
on that by category
sure
we have a paid for house 255 000
cash 170 000 emergency fund 32 000
22 000 hsa 129 000 in some other
equities
uh 540 000 in retirement
uh and then
you know the rest is in a 529. very good
how old are you
i am 35 my wife is 34. excellent how
much of this 1.2 million did you inherit
zero okay and what's your best working
year
of your working lifetime household
income and worst working year
this year is
slated to be the best uh our base will
be somewhere around 3 30 potentially at
the 372
depending on how bonuses pay out early
on when we got married it was 45 000.
cool what do y'all do for a living
i am an i.t security and risk management
and my wife is in accounts payable and
is also a real estate agent wow you guys
are killing it this is great so what's
your degree in
i have a bachelor's in mis and computer
science and an mba and my wife has a
bachelor's in business administration
and entrepreneurship wow what's your gpa
when you're in school
i was a 3-8 both for undergrad and
graduate my wife was three-eighths okay
good cool
okay well done you did this quick man 35
years old proud of you so uh can this
still be done if you're 25 listening to
this
absolutely it can be done earlier if you
start earlier too that's what we kick
ourselves about the biggest mistake was
not not doing it earlier wow how old
were you guys when you started this
uh when we really uh got focused uh you
know stumbled across the ramsey
team it was our late 20s probably 26 27
and then when we we just got focused and
got to it so in under 10 years
you're able to accomplish this that's
amazing because a lot of people think in
their minds well yeah i'll get there
when i'm 65. i don't want to wait that
long but it doesn't take that long when
you're intentional yeah the average is
17 years you guys did this really fast
but you have a way above average income
so you were killing it so that's pretty
cool well done man very very well done
all right what do you tell people the
secret to becoming a millionaires
you have to know your your why and you
have to set your sights on a goal uh
both my wife and i
want the ability to control time you
know to do what you want when you want
where you want it as long as
you have the ability to separate
yourself from the system and not have to
make a payment to another that gives you
the ability to spend your time define
what gives you that true level of
happiness and no no stuff can offer that
a lot of wisdom there that's pretty
profound wow
separate yourself from the system i love
that
stick it to the man
i love it absolutely that's very cool
very good hey man we're very proud of
you congratulations very well done rob
sean is next sean's in louisville
kentucky sean what's your net worth
i'm right at a million dollars dave look
at you
and uh how old are you
i am 33 years old a bunch of young ones
today all right good okay i love it so
give me a little breakdown on your
million dollars how's that broken down
by category
yes i have a paid off house right at a
half a million dollars i own some other
real estate property at 200 000.
have a roth ira at about 200 000
and the rest isn't in
cash good for you and what's your best
year working income worst your working
income since you started
well i i vary a lot on my salary i'm i'm
in sales and so best year was right at
half a million dollars that was a few
years ago and then uh but when i started
in my industry i was started and helped
out and so i was making minimum wage
right at about eight dollars an hour and
just worked my way up in the industry
and and now i i lead a sales team okay
what do you sell
so i sell it south software okay
excellent all right very cool
well that's making a lot of sense do you
have a degree
i actually have a degree in biblical and
theological studies and a master's in
pastoral counseling so i got into the
industry to pay my way through school
and next thing i knew i had
had kids
and
made a career out of it love it what was
your gpa when you're in school
uh 3.85 is what i averaged golly okay
good good
okay so you've made a lot of money and
that's part of the what has contributed
to this you've had some really good
years
what else do you
attribute this level of success at 33
years old to
well dave i've during that time i've had
a lot of hard years and so a big portion
of it was just always staying out of
debt
especially early you know when i was
pulling in
twenty thirty thousand dollars a year
um you know if a car breaks down it
could have been one thing that would
have set you back and it would have been
very hard to survive so just you know
always having that emergency fund
living within your means
but also being proactive with my savings
so i'm very much the type that
if i have to do something i tend not to
do it because i just get busy and so
within my savings i was having that
automatically pulled out i was maxing uh
out my 401ks and so i just didn't need
to think about my savings plans yeah
yeah
get after it was this instilled in you
from parents where did all this come
from this mindset
it very much was my dad he you know he
kind of taught me the power of compound
interest
at a young age and he would tell me you
know the math problems that if you save
starting young what it would be worth
when you were older and uh so he talked
that through with me and uh also taught
me the lessons that he learned you know
with um with making different financial
decisions one of which was never buying
a new car so he always bought a car with
50 000 miles on it and right now i'm
driving a truck with 198 000 miles on it
wow that's amazing
[Laughter]
well done
well done i love it well congratulations
brother we're very very very proud of
you so you're the moral of the story for
you is it still can be done
it absolutely can and you know i also
had a i went unfortunately went through
a divorce which was the hardest time and
so i lost in the middle that lost half
my assets
within that and you know just being out
of debt it was what made me survive it
just took that stress off of me yeah wow
and still come back at 33 with a million
dollar net worth pretty amazing
well well done sir thank you for sharing
your story this is uh this is how it's
done
so george we've been doing these uh
millionaire theme hours
baby steps millionaire theme hours for
several years now
um the number of times that um
someone calls and says that they are a
millionaire because they inherited it
and which by the way there's no shame in
that i do remember precisely one guy
calling and he's like yeah
i mean mom and dad followed your stuff
uh they had 10 million dollars when they
died they left us these three million
dollars
and um
no shame in that yeah and he's like the
way i'm going to honor their memory is
i'm going to do the same stuff they did
i'm going to stay out of debt and i'm
going to invest steadily and so
uh hey we don't throw any shade on that
at all we'll go with it you know that's
that's a wonderful story that's a legacy
story yeah but the number of times that
happens is very low almost all of the
people have zero inheritance or very
close to zero inheritance such a small
inheritance that it didn't matter
you know sometimes they'll joke and say
well my grandmother left me an old car
you know or something like that but
most of the time uh the thing they got
from their parents was work ethic
um
maybe they got from their parents an
example of what not to do yeah that can
be a strong why as well either way they
they did not have an inheritance and
they end up millionaires we're talking
to real millionaires this hour it's a
baby steps millionaires theme hour here
on the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our scripture of the day luke 14 28
suppose one of you wants to build a
tower won't you sit down first and
estimate the cost to see if you have
enough money to complete it
stephen covey said make time for
planning wars are won
in the general's tent whoo there you go
i like that it's a millionaire theme
hour a baby steps millionaire theme hour
here on the ramsey show george campbell
ramsey personality is my co-host today
the lies that are out there about the
wealthy are this that they all inherited
their wealth 89 did not become
millionaires
according to actual research not
someone's political opinion
well the wealthy are all crooks
nope
there's a percentage of the wealthy that
are crooks and there's a percentage of
poor people that are crooks as a matter
of fact there's just a percentage of
people that are crooks
and it actually runs about the same
really when you really get down to it
uh you know when a rich person is a
crook it's just it's it's with more
scale
it's easier to hate on yeah well and
it's you know but they're they're
actually crooks they just do i mean
burning made off they do it with scale
right more zeros on it yeah and uh so
it's more you know it's a bigger flash
when it happens and so
uh most millionaires most wealthy people
are famous entertainers
famous athletes
rock stars actors
no
less than one percent
of wealthy people are people of
notoriety
people of note that you would know their
name they're not household names
so there's wealthy people out there like
that they're you know they're the
and sometimes they're crazier than a
bean you know if they're in some of the
entertainment stuff that's out there and
sometimes they're regular folks if
they're in some of the entertainment
stuff that's out there but
um the wealth isn't what did it it's
just that they were crazy in a bean and
they got some money and so we noticed
them
and uh they can do crazy on steroids
you've met some of those people and some
of them are broke man we have we met
some interesting ones
uh they're all wealthy people i can't be
wealthy because all wealthy people are
brilliant they're all the 4.0 nope
haven't talked to one today they got a
4.0
um they're not dumb
they're not a 1.0
they didn't get a degree in beer pong
but uh
but they're usually around a three
somewhere three percent or a three
uh point something gpas what all of them
today have been anyway and that's about
right that's what we normally
occasionally run into a 4.0 but you
don't have to be you don't need to you
do have to be i mean smart
but you know versus dumb
but but you don't have to be brilliant
inordinately brilliant to build wealth
you just have to be smart enough to keep
doing your 401k and get your house paid
off
and that's generally what causes people
to become millionaires right there
gabriel is with us in clarksville
tennessee gabriel what's your net worth
it's about 1.2 million good for you well
done and give me a little breakdown on
that by category please
um
i have uh two iras two one for my wife
and one for me
uh how much is in the brokerage account
those um it's a little it's about two
220. okay 25. cool and then uh
a brokerage account and that's got about
uh 300 000 in it gotcha and then my
house is worth uh
uh 330 000. and then i have a
uh not a mutual fund uh um a money
market account that's got about 250 000
in it
and then the last category is i paid for
my kids college which came out to 165
000 and he is an investment now gotcha
okay very good
very good how old are you
i am 55. perfect okay cool how much of
this 1.2 million did you inherit
none zero all right and your best
working year and worst working year
household income
uh best working year was uh i retired
from the army but um uh it was 120k a
year and worse working here i guess when
i was a private you know making i guess
you know less than 10 grand a month okay
or less than a thousand dollars a month
right don't you okay
so your career was military thank you
for your service
you're welcome all right you have a
four-year degree
i do i have a master's as well okay
masters in what
mba oh good okay good and what was your
gpa
i think 3.7 on the masters and then
my bachelor's was like a 3.3
yeah people always get a little more
serious on the masters okay good good
for you man well done a little more
application of self yeah good okay so
you're 55 years old you're talking to a
young
private
that's 23 making no money
you can't be a millionaire
is he right if he says that
nope
what should he do
you should follow the baby steps and get
on a budget i don't for me that that
budget thing was hard when we first
started doing this uh 14 years ago i
want to say
and um
and not that we were in a lot of debt
but we would just spend money like crazy
and we own two houses and two mortgages
and we moved and so now they became um
long long just long distance real estate
which worked out for me
uh but in 2008 with the housing
market crashing i got upset that the um
uh the ceos of uh banks were still
getting bonuses
uh for that and you know me and my wife
were like we gotta get you know rid of
these mortgages instead of them getting
them the bonus one we get the bonus and
then i ran into a billboard that had
your face on it in uh greenville south
carolina i was teaching rotc at furman
university at the time yeah and i'm like
i gotta listen to this guy and you were
on tv back then
and um and we started the budget the
first one was very difficult and now we
come out pretty even you know we still
do a budget every month
and um and it took us we had a five-year
plan to pay the houses off
i got promoted and then i got deployed
which you know
in turn created more money coming in and
so that five-year plan turned into a
four-year plan
and um and haven't looked back ever
since and then you know we we readjusted
um you know how much we were investing
because we were all over the map you
know we were investing we were paying
mortgages
we were buying stuff we shouldn't have
bought
um you got focus now we're much better
you got focused you were doing a lot of
different things and you went let's just
focus on this one path the baby steps
and it worked
and you you still do a budget because
that's how you stay a millionaire
yeah live on less than you make
yep that's awesome what kind of car do
you drive
i have a rav4 and a toyota camry what
years are they
the rav is a 2017 and the camry's 2016.
of course i bought them both used
of course there you go if you want to
know what a millionaire drives
it's probably more like that than it is
the sports car next to you when you're
driving unless you're driving next to
dave and then you can uh you you'll know
you're driving next to a millionaire
well done gabriel i'm proud of you man
and uh again thanks for your service
that's beautiful beautiful work
excellent excellent job the good stuff
so guys this is how it's done
uh the point of this hour is to give you
real facts
that give you hope
because if you believe
that i can't be a millionaire because
everybody inherits their wealth then you
believe a lie
and we want to disperse that
if you believe i can't be a millionaire
because the only way to become wealthy
is to be crooked and steal i want to
disperse that because most of the people
we talk to are not crooks matter of fact
all of them we talk to are not crooks
and uh you know if you believe you have
to get a 4.0 i want to disperse that i
want to dispense with these lies this
mythology because it steals your hope
and these people out here that are
spreading this crap are hope stealers
yeah
you just have to do what actual
millionaires do which is have integrity
work hard do something logical and
consistent over a period of time and
you'll get there it may not be tomorrow
but i mean looking at these facts you go
okay well 10 years from now i could have
a huge turnaround 15 years from now what
could life be like 20 years from now
where could we be so you've got to have
that long-term vision a lot of them
mention that vision they had for their
life whether it's a debt-free screen or
millionaire status you've got to have
that vision you've got to do a budget
you've got to live on less than you make
none of it's rocket science today they
were young 60 39 33 35 33 and 55. wow
yeah sometimes we talk to 75 year old
ones and sometimes we talk to
65 year olds but and there's nothing
wrong with any of it wherever you are is
where you are
the trick is we want you to get about
the business
of winning
and don't believe these hope steelers
that are out there spreading lies
that puts us our the ramsey show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace
christ jesus
[Music]
do you love a good dave rand want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you